this Congress and this administration
likely will go down as one of the most
fiscally irresponsible administration's
and Congress's that we've had that
confession today after the Congressional
Budget Office chief said that the
recently passed tax bill and spending
bill combined will cause deficits to
grow by four trillion dollars over the
next ten years corker is not the only
one flummoxed by the one-two punch of
that forecast the president's new
economic chief this week is sending
Congress a package to trim back what it
budgeted last month we are looking at an
enhanced rescission package I think the
Republican Party on the hill has finally
figured out he's right house
conservatives fresh from an Easter
scolding by constituents for what they
consider to be reckless spending will
vote tomorrow on a balanced budget
amendment but a two-thirds majority is
required and Democrats won't bite they
go for and call this so-called balanced
budget man
it is not balanced and it should not be
an amendment to the Constitution the CBO
did acknowledge the tax cuts have helped
stimulate the economy the Treasury
secretary believes there's more to come
we're really just beginning to see the
important economic aspects of that but
neither party appears capable of taking
responsibility for outlays that outpace
revenues the single biggest cause of it
the aging of America and resulted in
title mmus Medicare Medicaid and Social
Security he said that I said cut
Medicare and Social Security I have
never said cut them already if I'd
misquoted you that I'm sorry but some of
your colleagues especially in the house
have talked about cuts to Social
Security and Medicare Speaker Paul Ryan
is one of the few who's attempted
reforming entitlements and he's leaving
soon and now a new deficit threat may
emerge a long-feared rise in interest
rates just the net interest payments is
gonna triple over the next ten years
that's big bigger than all of defense
spending the good news is while critics
scoffed when the Trump administration
claimed it could achieve three percent
growth in the economy in fact it did so
for three quarters in a row